in the Canadian Rockies a battle of
Olympic proportions echoes through the
mountains
the contestants are bighorn sheep young
and old Rams alike looking to make their
mark the prize is mating rights and the
chance to woo the local use with a
number of males interested there's only
one way to settle the matter
head-butting they smash into each other
with 40-pound forms absorbing the shock
with double-layered scholars whoever is
left standing at the end is the winner
they are fierce competitors strong
tireless determined and willing to use
every trick in the book to achieve
victory this one pretends to graze to
throw his opponents off guard
an old ploy it doesn't fool the others
two-on-one is a good tactic as our shots
from behind soften a ram up
and a low blow when no one's willing
the use watch and wait for a winner
but just because one Ram comes out on
top doesn't mean the females will accept
him after besting his rivals the lead
Ram now has another challenge pursuing
the females up Rocky Mountain slopes and
proving a strength once again the other
males unwilling to admit defeat wait for
their chance to bring the front-runner
down finally he proves his worthiness
the use consent their children will be
strong and Hardy
for now he is the champion until next
season when the competition begins again